alrededor de medio centenar de muertos
en las mayores protestas en décadas en
Perú y por imágenes como estas la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos está en una gira de tres días en
el país después de semanas con la vista
puesta en la crisis social la comisión
fue a recoger testimonios de víctimas en
juliaca donde el lunes murieron 18
personas en la jornada más Sangrienta de
las protestas pero también fueron hasta
Arequipa ica y Lima en la capital la
presidenta Dina boluarte recibió a
estuardo ralón primer vicepresidente de
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos y al comisionado Joel Hernández
que encabezan la delegación contra la
presidenta Hay un gran malestar social
por la gestión de la crisis y las
acusaciones de violación de derechos
humanos de la policía luego de
un intento de golpe de estado del
expresidente Pedro Castillo no pensé que
iba a haber tremenda violencia a nivel
nacional
teníamos que tomar medidas necesarias
para salvaguardar la vida y la
tranquilidad de los 33 millones de
peruanos y peruanos la comisión dará una
conferencia de prensa el viernes para
compartir sus conclusiones siguiendo su
mandato de garantizar la defensa de los
Derechos Humanos la cidh Es un órgano
principal de autónomo de la organización
de los Estados Americanos Aunque su
mandato surge de este organismo
precisamente una misión de alto nivel de
la oea ya había visitado Perú entre el
20 y 23 de noviembre en la que recomendó
una tregua política y diálogo esta había
visitado Perú a petición del derrocado
presidente Pedro Castillo en prisión
preventiva desde el 7 de diciembre tras
disolver el congreso que iba a reunirse
para votar su destitución en medio de
señalamientos de corrupción
desde su encarcelación manifestantes y
partidarios de Castillo han estado
exigiendo la renuncia de boluarte el
cierre del Congreso el adelanto de
elecciones a 2023 y una asamblea
Constituyente